[Música]
y analizamos cómo se perfilan las
elecciones generales en brasil que
tendrán lugar el 2 de octubre 2022 para
elegir entonces al presidente
vicepresidente y también al congreso
nacional a pasar a pesar de que no hay
ninguna candidatura confirmada el ex
presidente luis ignacio lula da silva
continúa a la cabeza en las intenciones
de voto con el doble de apoyos sobre el
actual mandatario estamos hablando de
jair bolsonaro pero ambos pierdan fuerza
con el ex juez sergio moro este último
es señalado por los analistas como el
posible candidato del centro que puede
romper la actual por polarización en ese
país entre bolsonaro y lula de acuerdo
con encuestas lula sería el vencedor
absoluto ante cualquier contrincante
pero sólo obtendría el triunfo en una
segunda vuelta no ocurre lo mismo con
bolsonaro que incluso sin la presencia
del líder sindical sería derrotado por
moro en una segunda vuelta presidencial
entonces para ello damos la bienvenida a
nuestro primer invitado ls marcio
coimbra analista político y presidente
la fundación de la libertad económica
gracias a marcio por estar aquí con
nosotros en directo américa de francia
24 entonces cómo se perfila estas
elecciones presidenciales en brasil
hablamos de estos tres candidatos y
porque sergio no sería una sorpresa que
podía estar metiéndose en esta segunda
vuelta si es que pasan en estas
elecciones de 2022
muchas gracias por la invitación raúl
por estar aquí en plástica 4
yo creo que hablaste muy bien en brasil
ahora tenemos una polarización muy
grande entre la derecha donde está
bolsonaro en la izquierda donde está
lula pero tenemos un sitio está en el
centro que puede ser ocupado por una u
otra persona y presentarse ahora el ex
quiz sergio juro que es muy popular en
brasil como una novedad alguien que
puede quebrar la polarización entre la
izquierda y la derecha e intentar ganar
poder se pone siempre tiene en las
encuestas ahora algo como el 10 por
ciento 11 o 12 por ciento depende del
instituto
que miramos con los resultados pero lula
está adelante y lula seguramente va a
estar en la segunda vuelta hay una
disputa
y brasil raúl para saber quién va a
disfrutar la segunda vuelta fórmula se
va a ser un candidato de siempre como
sergio puro o como el presidente
evolucionar de derecha marcio como está
hablemos del presidente evolucionar o
cómo está la popularidad del mandatario
pues hablamos también de la pandemia con
la gestión de su pandemia que no ha sido
bien vista por mucha parte de la
población también hablamos de la
deforestación de la amazonía como está
la popular la popularidad de evolucionar
en este momento
la popularidad de bolsonaro no es buena
bolsonaro tiene un sitio donde está muy
confortable que son sus apoyadores es
algo como entre 14 y 15
19% entre estas personas bolsonaro sigue
y naval hable pero con las otras
personas es su popularidad ha perdido
tracción ha perdido fuerza en los
últimos años y los últimos meses en
especial con el problema de la pandemia
en la gestión de la pandemia el
presidente con ella la pandemia no tomó
ninguna vacuna hasta ahora
y habla de las vacunas de una forma muy
mala y su popularidad no es muy fuerte
no está sólida entre el restante de la
población hoy cerca de 60 65 por ciento
de las personas rechazan el presidente o
sea el presidente no puede elegirse con
este rechazo del 65 por ciento de las
personas por ejemplo si tenemos un 1 en
la segunda vuelta con un camaro lula
gana con mucha facilidad y creo que
sergio muro también se llega a una
segunda vuelta con bolsa mario ganaría
pero como dijo antes en la segunda
vuelta seguramente estaremos 1
y hay una disputa por el segundo por el
segundo puesto en la segunda vuelta que
sería entre muro impulsión ar es posible
que mora ugalde bolsonaro en la primera
vuelta lleva a la segunda vuelta un luna
marcio le pregunta ahora cómo se
comporta el electorado de brasil en el
caso entonces si tenemos estos tres
candidatos para disputarse la
presidencia el año que viene hacia qué
parte de la población tendría que
apuntarle para tener más apoyo social
como además quedan los jóvenes en esta
próxima votación
general en brasil
los jóvenes se sitúan a la izquierda
pero hay en brasil siempre una posición
una parte de los jóvenes que están más a
derechas en especial en los últimos años
con la acción de la derecha en brasil a
esto ganó mucha fuerza y esta fuerza
entre los jóvenes se presión mucho mucho
en los últimos años a la derecha pero a
la izquierda siempre tradicionalmente en
los jóvenes del de más identificación
entonces yo creo que para estas próximas
elecciones los jóvenes tengan una a una
a una
una situación muy peculiar porque voy a
tener entre derecha siempre pero van a
tener un candidato de
izquierda de vuelta que es fuerte es
lugar o sea me parece que lula viene muy
fuerte entre los objetos ahora marcilla
para terminar nuestra conversación de
cara a estas elecciones generales de
brasil del próximo año cuáles son los
retos que tendría el próximo mandatario
brasileño como está actualmente brasil
en tema político social económico
el tema más importante que tenemos hoy
en brasil es la pandemia y la economía
la economía mucho más que la parte
social la economía de brasil va muy mal
bolsonaro no logró éxito no logró tener
apoyo en el congreso para intentar
ningún tipo de reforma y se habla mucho
que embolsó narón intentó hacer nada que
prometió en campaña
entonces la economía de brasil está muy
suelta y va muy mal va muy mal porque
las tasas de interés van a muy altas
como una de las más grandes del mundo y
la inflación es muy fuerte ahora en
brasil el poder de compra de la
población está muy bajo la gente está
perdiendo poder de compra la inflación
de los alimentos es muy fuerte mucha
gente en la extrema pobreza y esto
agrava el problema social o sea el
social como consecuencia de un problema
económico yo creo que el desafío mar pl
próximo mandatario es laico no